- It's my first day of proper work!
You can't shout at me.
- And if I shouted (mumbles).
You're not a small baby.
You're grown up.
You have a beard and everything.
(fast, upbeat instrumental music)
- I'm a physical
therapist and I'm gonna be
trying out the stuff that my mom does
'cause I don't think it's that big a deal.
- This is my dad.
He's been running the shop since,
how many years?
- Last 40 years.
- Mom used to teach us, actually
and today for the first time, I'm gonna be
trying to teach kids.
- [Voiceover] What is that? You make
lines and (mumbles)?
- Oh my God.
You are the hardest.
- You throw some paint.
- Throw some paint?
Yes, take buckets and throw.
- How can you do the same thing every day?
You don't get bored.
- You don't get bored
of doing the same thing,
shooting, shooting, shooting every day.
- You said it is just straight lines.
- It is.
- I want you to try this.
- I was waiting for this one day
(mumbles) could be teaching and I could be
taking a feedback from him.
- Today, I brought my son, Sumed here.
And Sumed, usually this
happen a lot of opinions
about how teaching should be imparted.
(speaks in foreign language)
- What?
Chill.
- What chill.
- How big should I be making this?
(fast upbeat music)
Where's mom?
(speaks in foreign language)
- So for a video like
this, I need to get your
attention in the first 30 seconds.
(speaks in foreign language)
- Are these identical?
Apart from the color.
(speaks in foreign language)
- Huh?
- I didn't mistake.
(speaks in foreign language)
He's every Indian father ever.
- Being doctor is so much more challenging
and there's so much brainstorming
and finding solutions.
- It keeps breaking.
It's not supposed to break.
- Because there is so many people
who watch content to show other people
that they watch it, as opposed to
really appreciating it.
I was one of those back
bencher guys who would just
sleep off after a while.
It's damn irritating when you are
on the other side.
(speaks in foreign language)
- Does this ever happen to you?
You know that there is a girl
in the last bench who
just doesn't give a shit.
- Yeah, you know, there are many people
don't give a shit.
(speaks in foreign language)
- I just felt judged and everything.
- Yeah, but that you will.
- You said straight lines are so easy
and you have not been able
to make any straight lines.
- Yours are also not straight.
- I'd love to teach
again, but I don't know
whether I'd be able to
do five hours a day.
- Like for 33 years like me?
- You can't really tell
how much effort is put,
how much expertise is put.
The hand that's required, the skill.
- Oh, God.
Pappa don't.
- You know what?
You can be an artist, but
I can never be a doctor.
- Bye (mumbles).
(upbeat instrumental music)